- So what's like your craziest
experience with a fan?
- Craziest experience;
I'd probably say the time
a fan came up to me
and she asked me to write: love is love.
And I, for some reason, I misspelled love
but she was gonna get
a tattoo on her wrist.
And I was like, "I'm so sorry."
And she's like, "No, no,
no, I'm gonna keep it."
So I haven't seen it today, but I'm sure
if you see someone that has love is love
with the love crossed out,
that's probably my artwork.
- Oh my god, wait, so wait,
you ended up crossing out
the love; now it got cool.
So love is dark.
It's a dark tattoo, mind you,
but I think it's cool, yeah.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I crossed it out
and rewrote it and she was
like, "I'm gonna keep it."
And I was like, "Okay, cool, awesome."
- I get so nervous when people do that;
they ask me to do lyrics,
and I don't know why I'm doing it.
And then they're like, "I'm
gonna get it tattooed."
And I'm like, "I can't express to you
how bad of an idea that is actually.
Like, you shouldn't do that."
I was like, "You might hate
me one day. I'm just saying."
Like, you could be like,
"She sucks," and it's there.
Anyway-
- It's so much pressure
'cause I'm like, "All right,
now it's 'do I do cursive?
Do I do box letters? What do I do?'"